ja während der krieg mittlerweile auch
nach russland nach moskau selbst zurück
kommt geht er auch in der ukraine weiter
wir wollen uns ansehen was im osten des
landes passiert dort haben wir heute
morgen schlechte nachrichten von der
ukrainischen armee gekriegt nämlich dass
russische truppen hier weiter vorgerückt
sind nördlich von rohrbach mut in der
region donetsk wer in oslo hans hier im
osten bereits kompletter oberfrank
russen jetzt gibt es weitere vorstöße in
donetzk und wir wollen uns aus dieser
region hier unten aus der stadt marinca
bilder ansehen marica ein ehemaliger vor
ort von den es seit einigen jahren eine
front- statt
10.000 menschen haben hier mal gelebt
und wir sehen mal wie das heute aussieht
eine weiterer ort um das immer mal
wieder klar zu machen was dieser krieg
aus diesem land macht aus dem osten
macht da ist nichts mehr da erlebt kein
einziger mensch mehr wir haben jetzt
hier aufnahmen der ukrainische armee die
versucht einen russischen vorstoß ein
infanterie vorstoß hier mit mörsern zu
stoppen das gelingt ihr auch aber der
ort eben zwischen den beiden parteien
quasi liegt er wird immer mal wieder von
den russen versucht ihr vorzudringen die
ukraine versuchen sie aufzuhalten dass
also das bild in dieser ehemaligen
10.000 einwohner stadt marjah völliger
zerstörung kein einziges haus mehr
bewohnbar und alle menschen natürlich
geflüchtet entweder in richtung kiew
oder eben auch millionen mittlerweile in
die europäische union wir wollen es
angesehen aufnahmen von der krim via
erinnern uns im letzten tagen immer
wieder ukrainische angriffe auf die krim
gab gestern es eine drohne geflogen bis
nach sewastopol ganz im süden und hat
dort das hauptquartier der
schwarzmeerflotte getroffen die russen
sind ein absoluter panik und wie panisch
die sind das sehen wir an diesen neuen
aufnahmen die man sich kaum vorstellen
kann wir sehen hier noch einen ganz
normalen strand und darüber ein
armeehubschrauber der russischen armee
wie gucken weil schon mal genauer an der
fliegt direkt über die menschen über
diesen völlig verdutzt wie kann das sein
in fünf metern höhe oder zehn metern
höhe fliegt ja direkt den strand entlang
und wir sehen uns noch mal genau an was
ihr macht das ist nämlich hochgradig
gefährlich was er tut der fliegt da
nicht bloß lang sondern jetzt kommt mir
das mal genauer an das ist der
hubschrauber das ist ein mi 8 der
russischen armee der offenbar so tief
liegt weil er angst hat weil er angst
hat zum einen dass hier eher
abgeschossen wurde und was auch dafür
spricht dass er angst hat ist dass er
diese flairs diese leuchtkörper
verschießt also hitze körper verschiesst
und das sind 1700 grad heiße körper die
er ins meer aber wir sehen das sind
überall menschen im jahr die baden und
wenn einer von denen ab kriegt er gerade
das vorstellt oder der gerade das
schwimmt das dauert minuten ehe das
wasser dass ihr das hier abkühlt
insofern eine tödliche gefahr für die
touristen und ein weiterer grund weshalb
immer mehr russische touristen natürlich
auch die krim verlassen wir sehen uns
das an erschießt also immer weiter diese
flairs immerhin nur richtung wasser aber
auch dort sehen wir immer wieder leute
im wasser mit anderen worten eine
tödliche gefahr für die menschen dort
und die touristen von der krim sind alle
an flüchten zu guter letzt wollen wir
uns bilder ansehen die auch ein bisschen
ungewöhnlich sind wir haben immer wieder
in den letzten monaten gesehen wie die
ukraine von ihren kleinen selbstgebauten
drohen bomben werfen auf die russen hier
in den einstellungen und wir sehen uns
dass man kann das video beginnt ganz
ähnlich wir haben also hier unten einen
soldaten der hier steht eine stellung
und wir haben hier sieht man vielleicht
ein bisschen etwas was an dieser drohne
baumelt aber das interessante ist und
das ganz andere ist dass der soldat hier
nach oben guckt und er weiß dass die
drohne kommt und die wird in diesem fall
ausnahmsweise mal keine bombe ab sondern
sie wirft medizin ab sie wird also
medizinische güter ab hier wurde ein
soldat verletzt von den ukrainern wir
sehen jetzt wie ihr los rennt der soldat
wir wieder zurück geht in die stellung
und sich schnell wieder versteckt die
ukrainer nutzen also die drohne diese
kleinen drohnen nicht nur um bomben auf
die russen zu werfen sondern sie nutzen
sie mittlerweile eben auch um ihre
eigenen truppen die man vielleicht auf
dem landweg überhaupt nicht mehr
versorgen kann mit medizinischen gütern
hier auch zu versorgen
[Musik]